i'll put it this way
so we saw in uh a lot of news about
taylor lorenz you know taylor lorenz oh
yeah do you know taylor lorenzo mary no
of her her number so she recently got
demoted um because she publishes fake
news about a couple youtubers
now not every people aren't really
they're not calling it a demotion
they're saying she was moved from the
features team to the to the tech team
but now she's being called a tech
reporter
so if you're writing feature opinion
columns and now you're just reporting on
tech that's a demotion sure but um you
know she gets featured on msnbc
because of mean tweets
yeah we've been swatted eight times
we've had a cred we've had the bomb
squad show we've had credible threats
and my private properties unaffiliated
with this show with tenants in them have
also been swatted and you know
look i'll i'll say it i guess it's kind
of weird talking about myself in this
way as if i'm deserving of attention or
whatever
but some people a lot of people pointed
out hey like when one of the biggest
political shows is getting this much
threats and swatting and bomb threats
and stuff isn't that a big news story
but for some reason we don't crack the
news at all and i'm like this is exactly
what you should understand
when people threaten us with death when
we have to evacuate our studio for three
hours over a credible threat it is not
newsworthy to the establishment
when one reporter for the mainstream
media gets mean tweets and cries they
bring her on tv and they parade her
around because we are not a part of the
establishment
so
it might have to do with her
just being a woman and women's
grievances maybe a little bit being seen
is more important but i think
look cnn got bomb threats
and they evacuated and it was like the
biggest news everywhere i mean even fox
news doesn't cover what's happening here
we we we don't matter to that world
right even though we we we rival the the
the viewership in terms of the key
demographic for many of these cable
shows in fact we beat cnn in key demo
viewership in prime time
so when i when i look at something like
that
when i look at the crimes committed
against us it's not just the media
ignoring it it's the question of people
who are posting this how is it that tim
cass has been swatted eight times
received two credible threats and has
had you know that's just here we've also
had other properties swatted that people
don't know about
they're like why haven't the feds caught
these people and i'm like it's a good
question isn't it
it's a real good question i mean why
haven't they arrested the protesters
that are going to kavanaugh's or coney
baritone right well the better question
is why don't they care right and i don't
i don't think that they care and i think
that it's it's a little bit related to
this news story
with the texas republicans declaring the
election illegitimate and we may not
agree with why they're doing it
but i'm a little bit sympathetic to
their to their angst because they feel
like everything that they care about
everything that matters to them does not
matter to the people in charge exactly
this is a and this is exactly what was
uh happening prior to the first civil
war southern states
not a fan of them but they were saying
why isn't the law being upheld as we
agreed to it
why was the north allowed to ignore the
law and the south wasn't right so they
said later
i don't know what's going to happen man
but i know reading about john brown is
really fascinating stuff it is dude this
look
it's it's crazy because
he was an abolitionist and and he would
often talk about this the declaration of
independence all men are created equal
the golden rule and all these things i
completely agree with but he was also
he walked up to walked into dude and
shot him in the face
and and a lot of people called him a
madman they said he was insane he was a
psychopath
you gotta you gotta imagine what would
happen right now if some dude like
making the same statements as john brown
committed one of these acts the funny
thing is the left that props him up as a
hero would denounce him immediately yeah
because he was about freedom liberty and
yeah the declaration of independence
you got to change the language on that
one you have to yeah
they couldn't support that
but but yeah basically
texas filed a lawsuit let me let me pull
it up actually
texas filed a lawsuit texas v
pennsylvania in 2020
filed by the state texas attorney
general ken paxton uh blah blah blah
blah they said they alleged that georgia
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin violated
the u.s constitution by changing
election procedures through
non-legislative means the supreme court
said screw off
not a good way to go so what happens
if you say
i believe this was unconstitutional and
instead of actually getting that sit
down and that adjudication you're told
go away we won't hear what you have to
say
texas then goes and says okay
we've our mind has never been changed we
continue to believe these things
and
you know what really frustrates me is
the cowardice
of the supreme court
uh
and the media
because they were too stupid and
cowardly to realize
there are more elections coming
and if texas says we believe it's
unconstitutional only say we don't care
then they're going to say okay then what
happens come 2022. in the midterms
they're going to be like we don't we
don't we don't believe any of this is
legitimate which is literally what
they're doing what happens if in 2024
biden actually wins again i don't see it
as being possible to be honest but let's
say he doesn't run let's say some
democrat eric adams or gavin newsom runs
and then
wins and texas just goes don't know
don't care and this time they don't
certify the election so it could go two
different ways and i think there's a
little bit of a scale as to how that
could play out right they literally just
go and do their own thing they just
start ignoring the federal government
probably still sending in taxes taking
tax revenue in
that but but everything else they're
just not acknowledging it
and the other thing that could happen is
that things could get violent or they
could get incredibly violent
and
i think a lot of that is going to depend
in large part on the response of the
federal government
and how violent they want to get with
people who are trying to basically
peacefully secede
and i say peacefully secede i haven't
seen it yet so that's you know that's
got a little asterisk by it because
we'll we'll see whether or not it's
peaceful the first civil war was
peaceful for two months three months
right and that's that's the issue people
think that peaceful divorce is possible
but i don't think it is
why do you think it's not peaceful or
what possible so
the first civil war you had i think
seven states i could be wrong
they seceded they made a declaration
declaration and that was it for several
months nothing happened
abraham lincoln then gets inaugurated
and says nope those military bases are
ours there you go
so what happens is
you've got federal authorities federal
law enforcement officers and if a state
secedes and then tells the fbi the cia
dhs get out and they say no
it can't be peaceful
that's going to be a real problem
that's that's the issue and you know
it's what's what's fascinating is what
ulysses says grant wrote about it he
said that every state has a right to to
secede right
it just means that you will go to war
and if you lose you will live under the
rules of your of your your batters or
whatever you said your your captors or
whatever
so his idea was
you know you look at the american
revolution you have a right to say i
have a right to autonomy and and to
secede and you can try if you lose you
now live under the rules of those who
have defeated you and then he his
argument was
the union spent uh sacrificed blood and
treasure to admit these states into the
union
and there was a debt owed to the union
that if they were to leave it would be
like them giving being given free stuff
and then ripping them off and so that's
why they went to war see this is part of
my problem with government is not
everybody signed that contract no not
everybody agreed plenty of people were
born after the fact plenty of people
didn't have especially in that age they
don't have social media they're not
reading up they don't know they're just
they come into this world
they're just trying to survive and
prosper with their families
maybe maybe one good hope for us
with any coming civil war would be that
it would be a very slow withdrawal and
slow pull out i think it'll be ten times
faster could be because of because of
the internet and social the information
age yeah it's crazy to me that um
man i mentioned this in a couple
segments earlier i was watching avengers
infinity war which was uh i think 2018
right 2018. yeah you should know that
and uh well you're the pop culture
person so
but but i was thinking about like what i
was doing when this movie came out
and i was like
do we not realize how much the water's
become has started to boil in the past
four years yeah so i was thinking about
how people kept telling me since 2018
there was never going to be a civil war
and i was crazy
even today people tell me there's not
going to be a civil war and then when i
saw the story about texas and pulled up
texas v pennsylvania i was reading this
lawsuit i was like
this is this is how frogs boil in a pot
you can look at texas v pennsylvania and
see that you had i think 22 states
versus 22 states suing each other over
whether or not
the election was constitutional you had
members of congress refusing to certify
you had state legislatures sending
alternate electors and then you had
january 6 and there are still people
acting like nothing's happening
and i'm just like welcome
i don't think that there's going to be a
civil war i don't think it's even
possible i think because any war that we
get entangled in is global at this point
and it's not going to be on american
soil it's going to be all over the world
including on american soil but
something is definitely happening i just
don't think it's leading to i take the
authoritarian bet like abe lincoln that
we cannot
shovel this union this union is secure
the only reason we're able to have this
conversation is because of this union if
the union shatters we're all doomed
essentially like you think nuclear war
is a problem well
you count your blessings that you
haven't watched in newt go off
what do you think do you think there are
any parallels that can be drawn between
what we're seeing right now with the
encroaching totalitarianism and the
collapse of the soviet union
because that thing fell apart yeah and
people didn't have to go out and fight
and have streets filled with blood yeah
it was that the oligarchs wanted to
seize control i think that's big part of
why the sow union fell was like
orchestrated by the oligarchy in russia
to seize power yeah i can see that
happening here it seems they seem to
want to but it's foreign oligarchs that
are trying to do it i think the
difference is though with the soviet
union you had different countries you
had people who spoke different languages
you had people who were outright
effectively captured in the past few
decades
the soviet union lasted what was it 69
years yeah so you effectively have
russia just annexing other countries and
so what happens when you have country
imagine if texas
only spoke french and you know alabama
only spoke spanish
well then i can understand a collapse
because there's already a language
barrier although the closer you get to
the border the more people speak each
other's language this is the united
states we've been it's 250 years 250
plus years so this is
everybody speaks english we have a lot
of shared history a lot of shared values
now it's starting to be ripped apart by
these two different factions you have
the constitutional republic which is
people who are american and then you
have the multicultural democracy and i
suppose alex jones would call it the
nationalists and the globalists is one
way yeah
yeah the bank for international
settlements the bankers the swiss
bankers the world economic forums
involved blackrock trying to buy
american land outfit well it's actually
black stone is buying a lot of land and
black rock will tell you that that's
conspiracy it's black rock because it's
black stone even though they were kind
of spin-offs of each other or one spun
off from the other thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there